I know what's been going on I wasn't
gonna pee I was just taking my penis out
you've been driving me around but there
was something else happening the whole
time uh what are you talking about you
weren't just working as my driver Todd
you were becoming my friend oh yeah that
was happening well I could use a friend
right about now there's something I've
really got to get off my chest and if it
got out it could destroy the whole
wedding um no I'm not great with
sensitive information I don't know if
I'm ready to get married again don't get
me wrong I love Diane so much I didn't
have any doubts until I realized she had
doubts then I figured she's smarter than
I am maybe she knows things I don't you
are kind of unloading a lot of sensitive
information the last thing I want to do
is hurt Diane but I keep having this
dream where she's gone there's no
breakup no tragedy she's just gone and
my life continues without her hey thanks
for listening to all this you're a
really good friend Todd and said you
weren't able to give me any useful Intel
I had to offer up my restaurant but now
run my turf time for operation
I don't yeah sounds good you know with
my knack for coming up with plans and
your ability to hear them without
contributing more than three words at a
time we make a pretty good team don't we
taught you said it see Bob character
actress margo martindale is in police
custody tonight for her role in a failed
bank robbery Margo Martindale
but first pizza for breakfast the answer
might surprise you I know her but how
wait she was at the convenience store
the night I bought that video game and
ruined my rock opera she's the one who
asked me to hand her that tape from the
10 cent bin hmm
that means margo martindale likes tapes
and a tape is something you listen to
but tape is also a sticky thing you can
use to steal boxes boxes is what cereal
comes in what does it all mean am I just
grasping at straws weights straws that's
it
straws are used to drink soda or water
and plants need water and Bojack use
margo martindale as a plant at the bank
and the convenience store which means Oh
Bojack hired margo martindale to make me
find that video game so he could kill my
rock opera ah dude
[Music]